Nitrogen is an extraordinarily important element.
We could make hundreds of YouTube videos about nitrogen and still not tell you
everything. So Neil and I and Brady have been in the lab.
We've done what we think is some quite nice experiments.
Just to give you a flavor of some of the things about nitrogen.
So you will see me trying to smash a banana.
You'll see Brown is being generated sodium.
Isaid going off in quite a spectacular manner and one or two other things.
So it's really fun, but there is some quite solid chemistry behind it.
[Inaudible].
Liquid nitrogen,
which boils at minus 196 degrees.
Centigrade is used as a coolant all over the world in
laboratories and industrially.
When nitrogen comes out of the container,
it's obviously cold and you can see in the thermal imaging,
how the low temperature cools everything around it,
it also freezes the water vapor in the atmosphere.
So you get quite nice clouds of what looked like steam,
but it's actually tiny particles of ice.
[Inaudible].
I used to use it.
My shoes cracked through freezing and liquid nitrogen.
I never tried freezing a banana.
I wanted to see the professor trying to smash a banana.
When you pull things in liquid nitrogen fruit, for example, that contains water,
the water freezes. So the banana goes absolutely rigid.
And then if you hit it with a hammer or something else, the ice shatters,
and it can make quite a spectacular mess.
The salt meal hates chemists use liquid nitrogen. First of all,
because it's safe, liquid oxygen would cause,
or potentially it could cause fires explosions.
You've seen liquid oxygen and cotton wool going watch also easy to
obtain. It's a major component of air is quite cheap to make.
Also it has a convenient temperature of 77 degrees,
Kelvin minus 196 degrees centigrade,
which is a useful temperature, which freezes most things,
most gases,
most things that you use in the land sodium azide is
assault of sodium and a plus. And the ACE side,
I N N three minus eight side comes from the French
name for nitrogen assault in three minors is
potentially a very unstable an iron. If you heat it,
it can turn to nitrogen gas.
And two has a very strong bond between the two nitrogen atoms.
So it releases a lot of energy. So we tried heating surgery,
may side. The reaction is quite simple.
It goes to nitrogen gas and sodium vapor.
The sodium immediately reacts with oxygen and water vapor in the atmosphere.
So you get a orange colored flame from the
reaction of sodium.
[Inaudible].
Sodium azide is one of the components that's used in airbags in
cars, the car, if it's crushing heats,
a charge of safety may side, which is also mixed with some other chemicals,
it releases nitrogen gas very quickly and blows up the air.
Back.
One safety advice that looks likely to be compulsory soon is the controversial
air bag. This drawing shows how it works in a crash.
A small detonator releases compressed nitrogen from a tube and this
inflates, the bags concealed in the dash and the steering column.
But I've never seen it heated up. Neither Neil actually,
it's really quite beautiful when you heat it up.
[Inaudible].
Other resides particularly have heavy metals like lead silver notary
sometimes used in detonators to set off explosives because if you bang
them, they compose very rapidly.
Although nitrogen is very unreactive.
It can be persuaded to react with oxygen and it forms a whole
series of different oxides compounds that contain nitrogen and
oxygen and their properties are very different.
The most stable one is called nitrous oxide sometimes called
laughing gas and two O N two O has the property that it
dissolves very easily. In fact,
your brain and mine is largely fat and so into
a dissolves well in the brain.
And it's very good anesthetic it's used in childbirth,
but because it dissolves well in fat.
It's also used as a propellant for instance,
Brady and I,
and Neil has quite a lot of fun squirting out instant cream,
just to show you the nitrous oxide in it.
The cream is pressurized within two hours,
probably in to not a very high pressure atmosphere or a few atmospheres when you
release it, the dissolved into a bubbles out.
So the liquid creams suddenly goes into a foam ready to go on
your cake. Some of the cream, when I eat the cream,
there's probably some mentor left in the cream, but if you wanted to knit,
it ties yourself by eating cream,
you would farm it long before you had enough to have any serious effect.
The other two oxides of nitrogen,
R N O nitric oxide,
and [inaudible] nitrogen dioxide.
They're both quite unusual because nitrogen has seven
electrons and oxygen has six.
So both compounds have unpaired electrons,
which gives them slightly unusual properties.
It's quite easy to make an a to the standard way is
just to heat up. Let nitrates
Late night trade is late two plus three minus.
And when you heat it up, you form lead oxide,
which is a sort of slightly yellow orange color.
And you make enter two, which is a Brown gas.
And when we heated it up,
we got really quite a sort of substantial plume of energy, too.
[Inaudible].
And the to itself can,
because it has an unpaired electron can dimerize. Um,
two of them form N two O four,
and which is a liquid at room temperature.
And we've shown on one of our other videos can be used as an oxidizer for
rockets. For example,
the lunar module taking off from the moon used enter four
as the primary.
No, it's very volatile.
It boils at 21 degrees C so we have to keep it cold and we put it into the
reaction chamber.
There's another way of making enter too,
which is the reaction of concentrated nitric acid.
It's important that it's concentrated with metallic copper.
And we did this in glassware so that we could collect the
guests to see what happened.
So we had a vessel with the acid coming in at the top,
the reaction taking place and the tube at the side,
going into water. So we could collect the guests.
[Inaudible].
You can see that when the acid went in,
there were clouds of Brown gas generated the end or before,
and it went down the tube and they was bubbling as it came out.
Now we had some quite strange effects,
which we hadn't anticipated.
It's one of the exciting things about doing chemistry, demonstrations,
that sometimes, although you understand what's going on,
you see effects that surprised you. When you added a bit more acid,
the end two started dissolving in the acid.
It was already saturated in the acid that was there.
And there was a momentary pressure drop,
which was enough to suck back the water into the vessel.
And once the water was set back the end,
no two went on dissolving and dissolving.
So the whole lot filled up and the solution went nicely blue
with the color of copper nitrate.
The interesting thing about this reaction is that if you use dilute
or more dilute nitric acid,
instead of generating an a two,
you generate an O nitric oxide,
which is not very soluble in water.
So bubbles out and you can collect it in a inverted test tube,
But I know reacts very easily with the oxygen in the air to make
energy too.
So when you take the test tube of Eno out of the water air
can get in the oxygen in the air,
reacts with the it and makes the Brown and new to gas. Now,
the relevance of all these nitrogen oxides is
that in the high temperatures that you get, particularly in diesel engines,
the nitrogen in the air and the oxygen in the air can
combine to make small amounts of nitric
oxide and to nitrogen dioxide, a mixture,
which is conveniently called N O X because X is somewhere
between one and two.
These nitrogen oxides in the air are very bad for
the air quality. When people breathe them in,
it can cause all sorts of breathing problems
And enter to dissolves in water, make nitric acid.
So you can get that nitric acid formed.
And so N two and [inaudible] are important.
Environmental pollutants.
Why does this only happen in diesel engines and not current diesel engines
operates at a higher temperature than petrol engines,
which is why they are more fuel efficient.
So in terms of carbon dioxide,
the emissions for diesel engines are lower than perpetual engines.
You can get more energy out, but in terms of nitrogen oxides, it's not so good.
Thank you for watching. If you'd like to see more,
why not check out our playlist with a video,
for every element on the periodic table or 118 of them,
or why not check out objectivity a channel full of science treasures from Isaac
Newton's death mask to the human bones found under Benjamin Franklin's house.
I'll put links on the screen and in the video description.